hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play phobia fear of
the darkness now this is an older game
but it was recently brought to my
attention by you guys who have been
lovely on the suggestions thank you so
much I mean I've got a few games in line
that I want to play but your guys a
suggest and really help out so thanks
again everybody for suggesting this and
here we go once again I don't know about
much of it because it was just a link to
a download site as a post to a website
so I got to hunt that down later but I
will find it so that you guys can give
it a try check the description the links
not there help me out in finding it I
mean I'll link to download link if I
can't find the website that it's made on
but anyway the game creators Jones games
ax OB ah the fear of the darkness you
got it buddy
the 20th of January 1998 my name is
David Norton
I was on the way to my new job outside
of the town
it was my first day
I had still a couple of miles to go
suddenly became a fierce snowstorm
my car crashed and I couldn't move it
anymore
the storm was getting stronger and I was
losing boat
then I saw large manner in front of me I
knocked on the door a few times
when no one didn't show up I stepped in
okay whoa
oh wow that is dark I mean I've seen
some dark games but this is dark do I
have a flashlight or something cuz this
is dark I can't see a damn thing all
right I'm not going back out in that
storm um do I have like a lantern or
something inventory cuz it is like pitch
blackness I can't see anything
was that okay there's a clock on the
wall I think a grandfather clock in WoW
is it dark oh I'm going upstairs I guess
oh hello okay I don't have much to
navigate by but I'm gonna try just get
these windows here ah this is kind of
unsettling it drops me in right away but
I guess it makes sense if this place is
quite abandoned and the name of the game
is fear of the darkness well this is all
pretty much in line with what I would
expect okay is that a doorknob locked
what am I supposed to do I guess I got
to navigate by these windows which is
all I have I don't like this I don't
like this
like most oh that's a doorknob I thought
I got a flash black with Slenderman for
a moment there from oh hello that opened
up okay I know you guys can't see
anything but neither can i we're
wandering through the darkness together
okay I'm slightly disoriented cuz I
can't tell where I've been and where I'm
going okay here we go new area hello can
I get a flashlight pretty please key key
a we'll give it to me
I see it can I have it maybe maybe not
key please no all right then
I guess not what is that oh that's
another clock why is it's by the window
oh do not like that music okay there's
something on the ground there that I can
get by and I can't quite pick up that
lock or that key so something else in
this room maybe or maybe he isn't the
interaction thing no he is because he's
what open the doors I can't get that key
maybe I need to crouch and get it come
on I'm so close it's right there can I
have it please can I have it can I has
key I suppose not okay anyway I am now a
loss what am I supposed to do if I can't
get the key I do not know but I'm going
back a bit I didn't even know I went
upstairs there I have no idea where I'm
going I can't whoa what does happen oh I
went down more stairs wait a minute I
don't remember coming up and down stairs
this is so weird I can't see anything
and I don't like it I don't like it I'm
in pitch blackness I did not come this
way this is new area well then how did I
get to how did I get to there okay see
ya he is the use button cuz I just
opened and closed that door it's gotta
be a way to get that key or there's got
to be a flashlight around here somewhere
looks like that's a negative everybody I
am lost lost scared and alone
clicking doesn't do anything okay
there's another door okay this must be
where I came in before but now it's just
darkness okay here we go alright this is
it this is it this is the way okay there
might have been something in the
beginning that I missed I'm just not
exactly sure I don't know how to get
back cuz it's so damn dark oh here we go
oh hello what is this
is that supposed to be a light really
that's a light oh you're kidding me oh
man this is just unsettling I don't like
it I don't like it I want something to
happen even if it's like something
jumping out at me I'd like something to
happen can't stand the darkness this is
oh whoa whoa whoa what was that what was
that whoa whoa whoa wh d open enter
enter to pick up keys why would that be
different oh okay okay
enter is it I I probably should it okay
ease just open and investigate but you
use enter to pick up keys items in and
see always objectives looks like there
hasn't been no one here for a long time
I should vaccinate the house and see if
I can get the lights on yeah that would
be nice
that would be very nice so I gotta hit
the enter button to get that key over
there and probably open up that that
little Locker that I saw but man is it
dark okay let me go in this room here
cuz I saw a Chester can I open this ah
Crouch no I can't open this one see why
is it gotta be enter that's so
counterintuitive but beggars can't be
choosers let's just move forward all
right lock it everything is locked see
where did I go this way I don't know if
my eyes are adjusting to the darkness or
something but suddenly I'm able to see a
bit more and I don't know why where
where am I woah hello
whoa what are you oh your door nevermind
okay here we are
get the key there we go got it finally
alright where does this key lead haha
that's a big question how about down the
stairs see if I can't go to the other
way like maybe this leads to a generator
in the basement
honestly I have no idea at this point I
really do not locked uh it's locked ah
woah what i just opened something i hear
something
something's opening up wait whoa where
am I now
where am I now where am I now what
seriously where am I now
whoa hello I feel like I'm walking into
something I do not want to see seriously
this is ridiculous
please tell me there's something here
what is that two bottle wine that's not
gonna help oh man I think this is the
door to the cellar it's locked the power
box I found a key can I go yes wait no
it's open yeah it's open what
no thank you oh that what are you are
you whoo all right then whoa what are
you Oh
looks like one of the fuses has been
burned oh come on No thank you who do
I'm gonna turn on the lights and
everyone's gonna be like surprise happy
birthday you're not gonna die what are
you thinking
okay okay fuses has been burned I found
another key though which means that I
should be able to go through that house
again whoa
thought I saw eyes I'm creeping myself
out more than there's anything actually
happening in this house I'm not really
scared of the dark but
what was that wait hang on oh that's
just the door to the cellar okay I gotta
go back through the house again there's
plenty of locked doors around the other
ways like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa here whoa hold on a second hold on
okay this is locked where am I going
I went down the hallway but there's
nothing there gotta go this way it's
just so damn dark that's so damn dark
it's so damn dark okay that goes back up
so this is the way I gotta go I got to
find one of the doors now we're locked
around this area and where's the hallway
it's the hallway sure wish I could see
something I really wish I could see
something oh no this is what is this
where's this sleep I don't I don't think
that leads anywhere I think that's just
a dead-end hallway okay where's the door
I got there we go okay here we go and I
open you yes I can oh no wait no that's
a different door hang on oh I'm it's so
easy to lose your bearings no that's the
same door man I want some lights please
thank you
aha I opened it what did I open though I
can't see die open this way whoa chase
don't bees there you are what what what
happened what happened was that a
monster saying there you are
whoa what the oh okay
I found a fuse and ah what happened okay
I found a fuse and I automatically made
my way to the basement so thank you okay
that's what that was it had to reload an
entirely different house cuz the lights
are back on now so that's good that's
good all right everything is gonna be
happy cheerful now right right everybody
right right it's not ready
oh this is nice all right
okie dokie hello
oh those that's where I got that I
didn't even know what that was okay
like not going back outside but oh if I
didn't known that door was there in the
first place
I would add a much easier time but I did
not oh man I was really good in the
darkness part I'm just waiting to see
what it has else in store for me I no
idea what the hell was going on it was
like it was the perfect analogy to
stumbling around in the dark trying to
find something I open this now No
oh hello where'd you come from find of
ringing a keys which means I can open
the locked doors and the rest of the
house maybe nope maybe not maybe I lied
like who could woo that is a grimy
looking bathroom
hello oh this is where I found the fuse
okay all right well I'm kind of sad that
I found it in there oh man these rooms
look like death these rooms are death
anyway I don't know what I'm looking for
now oh my what is my objective I got the
lights on I'm tired I should find a
guest room well wasn't that a guest from
over there by that with the keys maybe I
just need to click on the bed and go to
slip go to slip to slip
I should find guest room
this is guest room isn't it alright just
carry on let me double-check
why don't he just submit the catch from
just in case the guy in the manor isn't
gonna shoot me because some strangers in
his house
okay still can't really see over here at
least there's something hello okay this
is the room where I was is where I found
the key all right I'm sure that when I
go to slip things aren't gonna go so
well for me what's with this hallway
it's just a dead end it's weird
anyway where the heck am I gonna find a
guest room I don't know you tell me
this is all confusing to me I'm just
going down into the basement now oh wait
there was one more lock door right here
knob damn it where am I going oh here we
go I should go to sleep right away yeah
that's a great idea well then do it do
it man
do it up go to sleep right away oh there
we go got a stand on the bed I sleep
standing up straight in my bed I'm a
reverse vampire don't question me okay
oh great the lights are out again
my I don't have an objective anymore
great
what was I gonna what what what did I
expect to happen I don't even know the
layout of the house I didn't have a
chance to memorize everything so what ha
ha it's about time something showed up
all right then all right then let's
follow it wherever it went
don't know where all right oh no
objective still still fumbling around in
the dark all right where are we going
can't see a damn thing
cannot see anything all right there's a
door well let's get out of here that's
the same thing good thing there are
instructions to navigating the house
right then and there can I get out no
they go I don't want any okay
that was weird there's still a few
mm-hmm
what what is it bring it on
you want to go fisticuffs bro take you
I'll take you uh-huh no I'll take you on
man back out get ready for the Smackdown
duh I'll beat you to a pulp man you
won't even know I've crushed your head
like a walnut you want to mess oh oh was
that just a nightmare oh oh yeah the
nightmare for you what what I'm gonna
take you you never know what hit you
they call me greased lightning
good cuz I'm fat and sweaty hey yeah
you'll never catch me okay enough
posturing lights are back on and things
are no longer weird
and dun dun dun
dramatic music of your death bro ready
for the fight of your life was this okay
so where am I going now do I need to go
back to that room where that guy was
that would make sense that door is still
locked but whatever man
I'll fast through with my epic powers
can I get out of here and that nightmare
the room upstairs was unlocked oh I
should check it out oh great yeah
perfect
exactly what I wanted to do hi
it's a map well like I said before this
would have been useful at the beginning
of the game oh what's the point of that
what's the point of that
it's a map yeah okay wait maybe there's
something on the map that okay there's a
library and a bedroom the toilets there
stairs over there there's a storage area
by this one that I don't think I've seen
before but and there's also the library
and the bedroom I didn't know there were
two things over there so let me just
check storage okay I've already been in
the stories it wasn't anything here so
it's my objective I already checked it
out okay okay that's the bathroom but
don't need to go there it's rather
decrepit anyway any monsters want to
step huh you won't even know what hit
you bro you won't even know okay what
the hell was that okay there on the map
it said that there was something here
but there's no door that's why this
hallways that's why this hallway was
confusing me I don't know what that
sound was but it was rather
disconcerting
okay so there's got to be some way to
get through this to the other side don't
know how
though how the hell and what was that
noise like seriously how something was
swallowing a pill and cracking their
neck I don't know that's weird like I
didn't make a note of that hand let me
go back to the room maybe there was
something else that I needed to find it
cuz I noticed that there's another
bedroom that's listed on the map but not
there hmm
yeah it's see there is a bedroom there
and there's supposed to be a door there
but there isn't it's not there how do I
get in there I know I noticed this I
noticed this guy do you not take notice
of me noticing this I noticed this but I
don't know how to get in there maybe I
just got to wander the rest of the house
until it'll decide that it wants to tell
me what to do and there's got to be
something like a key or a hatchet that I
can break down the wall I don't know
it's gotta be something I just got to
find it that's the key to life there's
some just gotta find it
as I am too pro to be stopped by the
likes of you it should be right here
there should be a door here there's not
there's nothing to get by it okay let me
go downstairs maybe something in the
generator room that I've missed there's
also a locked door over here that
doesn't open and there's a bunch of
stuff down here that I don't know what
to do
can I go to sleep again no not yet I
don't know I don't know man I don't know
dun dun dun dun there's still a couple
of more locked doors just don't know
what to do about him what why am I stuck
oh hello
whoa why am I stuck what what is this
got a crawl under something mean I don't
know guys I don't know how do I get whoa
what's this
ah this is the way to the basement this
was while looking for C let me go back
down here
maybe there's something else that I
missed I mean there's just gotta be I
see what is what was that oh that was me
banging up against that nevermind I mean
there's gotta be something III I noticed
what it's getting it I see what it's
driving at but I just can't get it what
are these random noises no random noises
in my existence everything must be logic
and explainable logic mcclendon I don't
know I don't know no no I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what it was for me I'm not getting it
I'm not getting it I'm not getting it
bread I don't get it bread what do you
want from me brew I see what you're
driving at there's a bedroom there and
there was some weird noises but nothing
happened
I know what you're talking about okay
there's gotta be this has gotta be
something that I can do to get that
bedroom open gotta be some whoa what did
I just open whoa
some happen some here whoa I can see
something I can just there's something
here
what is opening okay that sounds open
did I open did I press like a button to
open the door damn it
Oh what am i doing I'm doing something I
know I am Oh what am i doing though what
I can't see anything
am i just opening a cabinet or something
I hear you what's going on oh it's right
in front of my face it's right in front
of my face but I just can't add two and
two together something in the storage
room maybe don't know
ah I was just that door sorry guys I
know I know you guys will probably
figured it out but I'm just I'm not able
to put two and two together here I may
be on to something guys I may be on to
something I may be on to something
in my mind I never thought that I might
be able to actually interact with the
object so maybe I can move this
bookshelf I just reread the note and it
said wait whoa whoa whoa whoa yes
get out of the way get out away yes I
did it yes oh man you can actually move
objects I just didn't think that I could
you gotta use the right mouse button to
drag objects around yes
it's a letter here's the key to the room
behind the stairs you got it buddy you
got it run behind the stairs okay so
that means over here down these stairs
maybe yes oh man my persistence paid off
sorry guys I know that was slow going
for me but I'm usually a lot smarter
than that well no I'm not okay
investigat is a map okay there's got to
be another secret room that is talking
about here I know there was another room
that was locked so there's only one
other room that I know about that's
locked and it's down this hallway down
the center there okay there's a whole
nother section of the house all right
let's go for that damn it I can't
believe I didn't think to I knew the
bookshelves were in my way I just didn't
realize that I could actually move them
okay we're in a whole totally different
section of the house now oh that's not
good that's in the way can I move you
and I move you I can I can barely move
it uh-huh
come on come on come on oh you're just
barely in the way come on turn turn you
bastard
turn you hairy bastard oh no I'm just
pushing it in the way ah hang on that's
locked I got to get this out of the way
but oh man physics are not working in
this game oh come on I can't I can't
pull it there's no way to pull like an
only push
just gotta keep pushing till it come on
you big fat bass there we go
follow that took a delayed reaction hi
what are you doing what are you doing
whoa hi there hey calm down there bro
hemp whoa whoa he wants me bad now that
out whoo oh wow
stop pushing me hang on there was
something back there yeah the way you're
not scary
Oh else is a clock you gotta be joking
me I thought oh no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no I got a key to something what did
I get
I don't have an objective no no in that
nightmare no no no no gods are that
daftar what did I get a key to there's
only one uh there are no other unlock
room where there get out of the house
damn it what other what other locked
room could there possibly be I don't
know I don't know I don't know what else
is there there's nothing there's nothing
there's nothing right there was nothing
in here god damn it those damn
bookshelves well what the hell this oh
that's bricked up cuz that's the door
that's the original door damn it what am
I gonna do what am I supposed to do
about this bunch on Oh dah it was right
there ah he still wants me bad oh hello
gonna okay the door immediately closes I
just gotta go by him come on good
oh here we go got it no uh no okay gah
gah ah what does it say you can wall get
up and walk it down can you walk behind
what can you walk behind it what does
that even mean
you can walk it up and walk it down
you're talking about the stairs right
can you walk behind the stairs maybe if
this guy wasn't here I must be talking
about the main stairs hi you want to
come through
you can't come through okay I get it all
right I just gotta go uh nope uh no no
no come on
I died please respond me at some place
where I can beat this thing no no I
didn't save I didn't even know you could
save oh man oh man
ah he was right in my way what was I
supposed to do find men stupid and
beginning and thought that clock was a
note if I hadn't known that Key was
going to that thing ah man that's so
dumb all right I'm not gonna quit I'm
gonna sprint through this as fast as I
can get back to where I was cuz I want
you guys to see the ending I want to be
able to see the ending I'm not gonna
give up on this just cuz I didn't know
that you could save or something I don't
know I didn't know you could save or
whatever I gotta skip the intro so I'll
be back you guys wait I'll be back okay
everyone we're back and we're gonna
finish this up sorry for doing that
thank you for bearing with me I'm gonna
get this cuz I'm not an idiot maybe
maybe not an idiot okay
hey buddy hi
you're a douche you know that running
what did I not activate him or something
what was that you can walk it up you can
walk it down can you walk behind it I
know you're talking about the stairs but
I don't think I activated my little
friend there hahahaha nice go me that's
what I get for trying to challenge
everybody I meet stop doing fisticuffs
with everybody okay that leads down wait
a minute
maybe these stairs are talking about let
me just check while I'm here can I walk
behind it I don't think so
I don't think there's a way behind this
one no they've got to be talking about
either the main stairs or that room with
the stairs they were talking about
before walk it up you can walk it down
McCain you walk behind it the only
logical thing is the stairs maybe I
gotta move this whoa hello hello physics
you're getting a little Gimli ain'tcha
excuse me I need to get through here
maybe ha ha
excuse me sir uh excuse me pardon pardon
my french but you need to get the food
out of the way what your son of a [ __ ]
move your fat butt damn it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what the all
righty then
yeah this is this normal that's normal
that's normal
not sure what the hell happened there
but yeah I was normal but if we got now
hello - let her search for answers from
the Attic come on I just got in here the
Attic what are you talking about stop
leaving me clues I could have gotten to
this place from the beginning I guess I
probably didn't even need to do anything
the Attic where the heck is the Attic we
save just in case
ah I'm going the other way
screw you I'm not even engaging you you
can go down in a failure for all I care
the Attic the Attic the Attic ha ha no
thank you Jesus
get away well you think you're doing or
the two of you there aren't you
hi hi hi I'm Lou angry I'm red okay how
do I get to the Attic how the hell do I
get to the Attic I don't know I don't
even remember there being an attic
search for answers in the Attic what are
you talking about here I don't know I
don't know is this it
this can't be the Attic no this isn't
the Attic how do I get to the Attic I
don't know whoa oh my Buddha noon
hang on maybe I could check the map
again oh man there's tons of yeah
is it doesnõt yeah oh we hang on close
that door behind me you see this how the
hell did you get to the Attic I don't
know hello I'm at a loss here
I don't really know hi buddy yeah how
you doing how you doing friend oh I kid
I moan oh no no no no no get out of my
way what are you doing why are you
guarding that what are you doing here
just you guys are everywhere don't I get
to the Attic
I don't know damn it it wasn't uh there
wasn't crap ease behind me isn't it
oh man guest room room kitchens there's
more stairs over there there's more
stairs this stairs down there's no
stairs up now I mean there's no stairs
up on the top floor is what I'm saying
damn it am I doing wrong here
Oh besides everything I don't know I'm
at a loss again hot oh you're guarding
it that's what's going on hi come here
you're guarding it that's why you were
there I knew god damn it god damn it
it's okay I saved thankfully I'll get to
the end this isn't gonna beat me this
went on way longer than I thought this
is gonna delay my whole day with the
games but man I'm not gonna let this
beat me you screw it I'm just as hatch
oh no I can't reach it
I need something what Oh killing me is
gonna kill me it's gonna I'm gonna be
playing this for 10 hours cuz I thought
it was a one video game and now it's
just murdering me this is unbelievable
this is absolutely ridiculous the hell
am I supposed to use to get up to the
maybe I'm not thinking plainly enough
maybe I just need to drag something over
and stand on it which means I gotta get
the other guys out of the way
and trap them in a room or something I
don't know damn it I'm gonna try to trap
him it whoa oh those are painkillers oh
okay
how duh okay come here I'm gonna try to
get this guy in the bathroom come here
cuz there might be something in the
storage area that I could drag out or
something damn it come on you're not
even gonna cooperate it whoa how'd you
get through that ow ow ow ow ow come on
deal with me here cooperate oh now oh
now you're stuck come on come here come
here come here
hook bro moves and then close the door
on him now there we go all right yeah so
he's stuck there we got nothing
ah-ha ah-ha ah-ha oh come on I thought
that whoa well I'm able to go through it
that's for damn sure
so this chair isn't good enough I can
see up above it but it's just not good
enough
maybe I got stack more I don't know ah
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe
maybe put the chair on this and that'll
do it can that do it nope that won't do
and I can get it better ah piss we go
come on get up there I can reach it I
can definitely reach it I don't know
what it's saying but I can definitely
reach it I'm right here man
I'm right there oh you're killing me I
don't know what it could possibly want
more from me but this is just absolutely
ridiculous
I'm almost just breaking through to the
other side just cuz I'm busting through
it it up there I said get up there bust
through it pass through it with your
skull and then go I've been wasting way
too much time on this ah this is
absolutely ridiculous it's it's long
since stopped being fun to play that's
for sure and I thought I was getting
closer to the ending and I'm pretty sure
that this is what I'm supposed to do but
I can't get up here because for some
reason it doesn't think I'm close enough
when my head is poking through it my
head is poking through the thing and yet
that is not good enough ah what the hell
no oh no what did I did what the hell
did I just do i ro I ripped it off
really you gotta be kidding me
you gotta be king you've got to be
kidding me you have got to be joking me
get on there what is wrong with you get
on there get thank you God all right
save all right I'm in the Attic if this
takes much longer I'm gonna lose my mind
I'm in the Attic now what answers could
I possibly want what could possibly be
rewarding enough for that my goodness
yeah the way I said get out of the way
oh man oh god not another one oh this
started out with such promise it really
did I just don't know what to say about
it now it became patently annoying after
a while and there's just long periods of
oh my god I'm gonna burn this place just
like Eric said in that letter I haven't
even read the letter yet oh I didn't
Karen a few months strange things
happened I woke up on the voices saw
strange things some guy come to the
manor and told me that he was on his way
to the city but could not continue
because of some an unexpected snowstorm
he asked if he could stay the night at
the Manor in the morning I found him
dead I hid the corpse in the cellar I
didn't know what happened it was an
accident or suicide and always the same
if someone stayed at the night or even
came to visit died I wouldn't want to
call the police because they wouldn't
believe me I was wondering if I'm the
one who killed those people this place
is making me crazy and I can't leave
because of the storm it only started a
few days ago but it looks like it won't
stop anyway I wrote this because I'm
gonna shut myself to the cellar I can't
life with these with these things I've
done it's the place please torches
immediately and don't tell anyone about
it alright
man oh man this is brutal but I'm I'm
already too far I'm sticking with it to
the end cuz obviously that's the last
thing that I need to do I need to find
fuel god damn you're joking right you're
[ __ ] joking me I'm so utterly pissed
off at this it's just aggravating it's
aggravating games like this should not
be aggravating and whatever I'm I'm gone
I'm gone I'm out of here
just get out of my way I'm gone ah I
need to find fuel where would I find
fuel that looked like fuel okay got fuel
where do I tore to where do I start this
conflagration in the basement pain pill
pain pills
okay I just got tough through it to the
end I'm almost done so let's just get
out of here oh man seriously guys just
spend like the most brutal experience of
my life I can't believe all not you what
are you guarding huh what are you
guarding you son of a [ __ ] screw you
hello what are you guarding you're not
guarding anything you're just waiting
for me to pop out there aren't you all
right
terrific what are you guarding I'm gonna
lock you in this room come here come
here come here I want to have a word
with you come here now stop being stupid
and go through the door
oh no not goddamnit
all right whatever what were what were
you guarding seriously what what what I
can't start the fire here can I I don't
know I don't know and I don't want to
know
close that door oh you're just waiting
for me to pop out on the other side of
that but I think I need to go to the
basement I'm not sure
close the door close the door close the
door close the door
thank you oh man what was that I'm gonna
but I need to find like fuel or
something I found like fuel or something
where do I put the like fuel or
something it went dark what what the
hell happened what oh come on oh no god
damn it the game froze I'm done just
[ __ ] I'm done let's say that I burnt
the house down and everything went
hunky-dory and I went on to live a happy
life and I went out into the world and
had a great time and this didn't waste
an hour of my life and this is gonna
delay my videos is if you don't know
this is why the videos were late today
cuz I've spent so much damn time editing
this video man had such potential in the
beginning but this is dragged on forever
with completely illogical things and
game mechanics that were broken and then
it crashed even as I was persevering to
the end and struggling to beat the game
and trying my artists and not giving up
the game crashes that was the least
rewarding experience I could ever say I
could honestly say that in the beginning
it was fine it was well paced I was
scared
and I was doing great and then it just
became this aggravating pile of god
dammit that was awful Dow's toes so
horrible and just the clues saying doing
nothing but trying to find a way to get
into a room that was already hard to get
into just to find a piece of paper to
tell you what you already knew how to do
god dammit
I was rough that was a rough experience
and I would not wish that on anyone
like so be grateful that I played as far
as I did because I don't even care if it
was a trick ending like oh you burn it
ha ha you'll never escape
the manner or I burned it and I went off
into the snowstorm and died I wouldn't
care I don't care anymore I just don't
care so anyway that gift saw a battle I
don't even care what you want to rape
that game on it started out great and
then went straight down into the ground
anyway that's it for now I'm done I'm
gonna go cry myself to sleep so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
up up here
Oh
bud
ah